what is Hillsong a Hillsong is a
spaceship and I it is a local church
that over the past thirty years has
really taken some ground in culture and
the easy answer it's a regular ordinary
Church filled with really good people
and sometimes we end up sitting in this
chair remind your soul tonight that God
is not just two steps ahead of you he's
already been faithful founded in
Australia Hillsong arrived in America
roughly ten years ago their locations in
New York and LA have attracted athletes
like NBA MVP Kevin Durant Oscar nominee
Hailee Steinfeld and artists like Lil
Wayne and of course Justin Bieber when
did you notice you are not only striking
a chord with a quote-unquote the general
public but also celebrities and people
of notoriety we're comfortable coming to
your church no if it was a particular
date I just feel like if you build if
you build the right culture naturally
organically things are gonna fit in
there so we didn't set out to say let's
have a church that reaches this person
or that person we set out with a value
let's have a church that reaches
everybody but yeah if you have a church
in New York or LA it would make sense
that you'd have people in the industry
because of proximity
well the Pentecostal mega church is
known for its contemporary music look
and feel it's also had its fair share of
controversy according to an expose by
The Daily Beast Hill songs original
founder Frank Houston was embroiled in a
molestation scandal and the church has a
history of practicing gay conversion
therapy their conservative stance on
issues like abortion were addressed
during Carl's recent appearance on the
view what I love about our church is you
have different races different faces
different backgrounds but people are
committed to one cause and so it's not a
sin in your church to have an abortion
that's kind of conversation we would
have finding out your story where you're
from what you believe yeah I mean God's
the judge people have to live with their
own convictions and I think if I have to
tell you
[Applause]
that's such a that's such a broad
question he later clarified his comments
this past Tuesday in a statement
tweeting that his response has caused
some confusion about our stance as a
church on this matter I do believe
abortion is sinful our prayer is that we
can continue to help and love those that
deal with the pain of regret from
personal choices rather than cast
further shame and guilt so despite that
backlash Carl continues to use his
platform to educate and inspire we're
trying to get our generation sometimes
you see the the Instagram moment is of
is a fraud it's a fraudulent moment
because what looks to be so perfect in
real number one that's filtered number
two is 19 takes number three there's so
much that went into that so yes love the
dream have the Instagram goal but be
willing to just make the most of what
you have right now because as we saw in
Texas not a single one of us has
promised tomorrow